this has been here for four days editor
applications i got shipment in what's up
editor applications i wanted to give an
update on that we received almost 400
submissions
thank you so much that many submissions
of people taking up that much time it's
overwhelming and it's really really cool
with that said i narrowed it down to
four people one percent of the total
applicants and uh that's where we're at
currently we're gonna be
bringing them in doing interviews second
and third rounds of interviews finding
out more about it i'm super excited i'm
really excited to meet these four people
i'm sure you will be too whoever we
decide on it's an exciting little
journey we're on here so come on it with
us oh also to all the people who rick
rolled me
only fell for that once
i got a shipment in oh this is crazy
you're not gonna believe this in fact
even after i show this to you you still
might not believe it
it's very real within these covers live
pages of an actual book that we are
actually going to be releasing i spent
so long
getting this done and i cannot wait to
share this with you guys top 10 games
you can play in your head by yourself
there's a notes section let me just say
that okay notes this is the kind of book
you have to go through and you're going
to want to write down notes crafting a
dungeon experience america end of the
free home of the brave a strong truck
being attacked by a four-wheeler
yeah there's some good good bits in here
[Music]
what's up sam how you doing doing all
right
instead of finding something that looks
like the character in your game you've
cast somebody that's the modern way to
do it right you cast somebody and then
you build the character around them so
the likeness of brett is in the game
he's doing the capture for it everyone's
like what are you doing with an iphone
making video games wow every time they
show you like facial capture for a movie
or like a video game they show you this
like huge rig that's bolted to you and
what they don't what the people who like
rent those out don't want people to know
is that that same technology has been
compressed into a phone by steve jobs
the ghost of steve the ghost of steve
jobs from the grave coded it up for us
animojis apple put like tens of millions
of dollars into making it so you could
like take any like crappy lighting
conditions and crappy handheld stuff and
get decent facial capture out of it all
of that research is way more than they
put into budget wise into those like
very fancy rigs like they can't they
can't afford like apple level engineers
to code that stuff so apples is actually
better so what we do is we take the
iphone 10s or the 10xs now i guess are
the two that have it as a feature and we
use an app called facecap what else and
for free
so that the phone when it captures it it
turns into like 52 float values right
like zero to one values for the
different blend shapes of your face so
there's like one for like a left corner
your mouth one for the right corner
mouth one for blinking one for eyebrow
up one for other eyebrow so it records
all that stuff and this app just gives
you that data once you've got the data
you take that and we make the exact same
blend shapes for brett
in game bread and that way he gets
driven by this gonna be a good game hey
check it out this is what the earth
would look like if there is no water on
it stay tuned sunday vfx artist
demonstrates the thing comes out on
sunday anyway but enough about that i
want to talk about something else that's
happening that's really cool i am giving
a ted talk it's happening it's official
on march 16th in philadelphia i am
giving a tedx talk turns out this is one
of the hardest things i've ever written
it's about how like cgi is used in
movies these days and whether or not
it's like bad or good and i kind of
explore all about that the reason why
i'm mentioning this at all is because
you can go you can come see it so if
you're in or around philadelphia on
march 16th that saturday afternoon the
ted talk will take place nick's gonna be
coming with me here uh we may do some
sort of meet up afterwards so if you
want to come hang out with us
philadelphia details to be announced
stay tuned i'm very nervous
how's it going it's good what are you
working on doing some testing we're
gonna be replacing our little cameras
we've been using for the podcast we've
been using these little canon vixia's hf
r800s which is just like a consumer
handycam but the signal it sends out
isn't the strongest signal if you're
going to live capture so this is
starting to prove itself we've got our
first sponsor podcast numbers are very
different than youtube numbers we've
learned in the podcast world we're
already getting up there in like
percentile of performance which for us
is very different because it's a whole
other world that we don't know anything
about it's starting to prove itself
we're getting good numbers and that's
because of you guys watching the podcast
listening to the podcast please share it
with your friends we need to you know we
need to keep going so that i can keep my
job we're going to keep having great
guests there's some really cool people
coming on we hope you guys like it and
we're gonna keep improving and keep
trying to do better and that's because
you guys are watching thank you very
much
how does it feel to be directed to be a
merch model uh it's way less stressful
being on screen talent every time i'm
directed as opposed to being a director
it's always just like a breath of fresh
air because i know how stressful it is
directing and when i can just be on
screen it's like
i'm just having fun
just stand here and
smile at the camera easy acting is so
easy
i got some good news guys or most
popular shirts back in store corridor
got a cool hawaiian print and guess what
we got something new for you oh look at
this sweatshirt keeps me warm keeps me
cozy high quality with an iridescent
corridor logo it's pretty neat oh what's
this on my head oh it's a corridor hat
these are also super popular backed by
popular demand restocked in the store
just for you do you know what the real
good news here is that this shirt is
back in the store not just because you
asked for it because i didn't get one
and i needed one
that's the seed boy
act accordingly
we now have our script for the prim tech
video we now need to go through and make
sure with clint that all the props and
things we're about to build and make and
buy are on point with the stuff that he
wrote so it's a very important part of
the process this is our buy and build
list i'm just gonna follow it here
number one steve's hut well we can
either do like an elevated one that's at
an angle or like a lean too but a little
maybe a little longer yeah like a little
thing like that with a little angle a
backpack we could just source that from
the studio are they giving us a bike
still yeah this technology says today
the bike was sent off to get power
coated we should have it back in the
next couple days then we'll be able to
assemble it working on the thousand watt
motor i can guarantee that we can
deliver a custom bike next week let's
just have that bike be the finished bike
yeah and then we can use our current
bike that we have or bamboo to like get
up to that point cool that's that's what
i'm saying yeah super 73 i mean if you
don't know how awesome they are already
this guy's legit well that's pretty much
it i'm super excited about this yeah the
last one we had a good time building out
in the woods for a few days i'm looking
forward to it
you know jared j and jay's just solving
problems in the woods man that's how we
do it
any more chainsaw this time around or
god dude yeah almost not that chainsaw
it needs a new blade yeah it needs a new
chain
but that was a really funny bts man yeah
that was amazing
what up son on my free time i wrote a
script created an animatic for like a
pilot animated episode for the corridor
channel i just called it corridor
dimensions my goal was to animate this
in blender with their new grease pencil
tool which is like 2d animating in 3d
space two minutes doesn't sound long but
if you're working on it it takes a
really long time i don't have a lot of
patience for full animation there'll be
a link in the description if anybody
wants to take a stab at animating it or
parts of it like i would love to see
that it would be pretty cool i also want
to shout out drew lehman i think that's
how you say his last name his fan art is
what inspired this kind of based it on
style i just saw that and i just ran
with like i made up a story based on
that stuff i gotta shout out that guy
for sure how's chopsticks going
chopsticks is going quite well i have
until friday to finish the video even
though it doesn't come out till march
9th so it kind of feels like you know
the tortoise and the hair i'm so far
ahead that i'm good i'm just gonna chill
we've worked in a self-imposed deadline
of friday i have two more vfx shots to
do here i go help gabe move this couch
with just my chopsticks that shot took
me like five days just explaining what's
going on here is hurting my head um it's
a clean plate tracked on to another
clean plate that don't line up and i had
to line them up manually frame by frame
and track them into the to the actual
footage and then i have a couch tracked
in that's not real and when i pick it up
it turns into a 3d scan of a fake couch
wren tracked the scene and then i had to
animate the couch perfectly to the
chopsticks and give it some wiggle and
motion and i had to like combine it like
perfectly so the two couches just match
up perfectly and it's a very fun vfx
intensive video it's not a flat earth
video
dude this guy doing freaking dry earth
over here you don't know what that is
yet it's okay you will on sunday thank
god i had sam and ren's help early on in
the process getting it done this week
wouldn't be possible without them
so there's a saying about throwing
stones in glass houses we're going to go
in the camera room and we're going to
see how well people have been following
the rules
this table is absolutely under no
circumstances is anything to be on the
table period i might be a culprit hold
on don't look yet one thing might be my
fault so just
what is this that's a node oh that's d
dude what is
this has a place this has been here for
four days what is it what is that what
is this i'm good
hold on sam this is your russian lens
dude
that's mine someone put them there
because i put them on the shelf next to
the tools you can't get to the screws if
but i wanted to keep this on hand next
to these tools we're just gonna take it
home four days this has been just my
pendants here it's done i'm not touching
that with this you can put it up
erickson the wireless model kind of
freaking dingleberry leaves this wrench
isn't the same
where are our red megs
i saw them when i would when i organized
the place i organized
maybe they're in the red media bin
they're not in the red media bin no
you're right all
glass houses that still doesn't excuse
the font nico look at this these are
perfect what is this anarchy i think i
think i'm mostly clear the small hd bin
was mine probably niko wrenching no that
was sam that was part of his landscape
you saw his little tool right next to it
i'm just gonna put your stuff next to my
problems from now on
i don't know if you guys have noticed
this about our store yet but items tend
to sell out pretty quickly because we
only order certain amounts so if you
want this sweatshirt your highest chance
of getting it
shut up
shut up sorry
your chances of getting it are highest
right now so go to corridor digital dot
store it'll be there waiting for you and
also these hats are there and the got if
you miss those just
just you know what to do
see you over there